I will let Jamie Foxx ruin my life and
make me a single mother the best
on-screen performance in the movie
Django goes to Jamie Foxx's penis damn
that thing was pretty but let me show
you something goddamn it won the Oscar
and the Oscar Mayer would you think it's
at the bottom of this mother I have to
kick into two parts carry the bass here
and the tip in here that's my new album
to call just the tip just the tip nuts
you and just the tip and nuts you know
that feeling when you're so horny only
Jamie Foxx will do and I come on all
different speeds too I come to you
babies rapid-fire huh you want to get it
you want to smoke a cigarette effort
grab a package of power Bowser's to give
this gin
I need a sugar daddy that looks just
like Jamie Foxx baby I got so much sugar
take your insolence baby because you're
gonna get diabetes and once I lay this
sugar in your vein sugar in your vein
yeah sugar in your vein with your steak
it's coming out on iTunes I would lick
Jamie Foxx all over TB f H get ready you
know say get all the caverns make sure
you got your GPS find the right spots
ways taking ways I went through somebody
living room it took a left with Harlem
my bad man y'all just just trying to get
to the hull of a boat I'm gonna come up
with love ways so you know how to find
your partner what they like
I want Jamie Foxx to sing something to
me between my thi never mind sighs it
would be like this Jamie Foxx associate
of 2018 BT to the worst mother right
we've got to have an incredible time
rock Obama's coming to be et Awards and
if there's any indication that America
needs me back asap we're gonna have
Oprah Oprah with ride it's Jay Z let me
start off with my see projects you know
it's crazy here gonna be at the BT
Awards last thirst tweet the part in
Django when Jamie Foxx saved Carrie from
the room and he said and it's sexy voice
yes baby
save me yes I'm here to save you baby
captains save them all that's what I
want to do and you can find my new
record tipping balls
what was it tipping nuts I get you know
the tipping balls is the is the European
release
[Music]